SCOTT CARPENTER: Well, it's
my great privilege honor
to introduce you to
Srdja Popovic, who's
a very old friend.
We're both not as
young as we once were.
None of us are, I guess.
But back in the day,
Srdja was working
on this small problem
in his country,
Serbia, where the country
was dominated by a guy
by the name of Milosevic,
who you may have heard of,
who was waging war
all around him,
was suppressing and
repressing and oppressing
the people, his own people.
And there was very little
in the way of anyone
to stand up to him.
And Srdja and a few
others very bravely
figured out a way to
use humor, and to use
the sense of being
everywhere all at once,
to change completely
the perception
of the society of having
no room to maneuver,
to making it seem almost
inevitable that Milosevic
would go.
And it was just
amazing to watch.
And I was living and working
in Central and Eastern Europe
at the time, where people
like Milosevic and Tudjman
and Meciar and a number
of these fun individuals
were wreaking their havoc on
Central and Eastern Europe.
And we've come a long
way in many respects,
and in some respects still
have a long way to go.
But in any case, Srdja
was one of the founders
of this movement.
And the movement
was called Otpor!
And "otpor" means "resistance."
And its symbol
was a raised fist.
I'm sure he'll tell
you more about this,
but one of the things,
when I was working
with him and some of his
friends back in the day,
it's so creative.
And so I'm really
looking forward to you
being able to hear from
him some of these ideas
that he has to share based
on a long experience.
Because after Milosevic
fell, he went into parliament
for a little bit and
decided at the end of day
that his skill set
and his passion really
lay in sharing the tactics and
techniques that he had learned
while he was
underground in Serbia,
and how to perhaps share those
tactics-- nonviolent tactics
and techniques, by
the way, nonviolent--
with the rest of the world.
So he and some friends of
his put together something
called CANVAS, the Center
for Applied Nonviolent Action
Strategies.
So he's going to talk a
little bit about this.
My own recollection--
a couple things
I just wanted to
share from that time
was the idea of small stickers.
This is one of the things that--
it was like thumb size, maybe
even smaller, that
had the Otpor!
symbol on them.
And what you would do
with these is you'd
pass them out to lots of people.
And they would
put them anywhere.
So you'd be on a bus holding
onto the bus, the rail,
and you'd just put
your sticker there.
And all of a sudden, all
over the city in Belgrade,
there were these stickers
everywhere for Otpor!
How did they get there?
And the regime would go crazy.
And I think it was the first
time the tactic was used
that has advanced
all over the place,
is they had these little
stamps where they would stamp
the currency with the Otpor!
sticker And it would circulate.
And the government would try
to take it out of circulation.
But it would be
too late, and there
was nothing they could do.
And Otpor! was
everywhere, until Otpor!
finally was everywhere.
There were 70,000 supporters.
People came out in the streets.
And Milosevic fell
without a shot.
And that was what
was most miraculous.
So I'm going to turn
it over to Srdja
to talk to you a little bit
about his personal story,
and then about the book,
how the book came about.
And then I'm going to
ask a few questions.
And I'm going to invite
you to participate as well
and ask a few questions.
So over to you,
Srdja-- welcome again.
SRDJA POPOVIC: It's great to
see an old friend in a new suit.
Congratulations for
working with Google Ideas.
I'm very familiar with
the work of Google Ideas.
I'm so proud to know people
like Jared Cohen or Dan
Keyserling, who is hiding
here in the front rank.
I'm so happy to be
with you guys and meet
some of your colleagues
on events like Zeitgeist.
And I'm very, very enthusiastic
about the fact that you're
putting at least the
part of your resources
into making the world more
better and a more open place.
Now, a little bit
about this story
and this little yellow thing,
which sits in your chairs--
I'll start by story of me.
And this is not a book about me.
I would never write one.
I would never even read one.
It would be the boring one.
But it's a story of a rock kid.
I started as a bass guitar
player in a Serbian rock band.
And I was thinking
that activism is
for geeks and people who are
fighting for animal rights
and stuff like that.
But being thrown
into the war land
and understanding that the
only way to do something
is to change, and specifically
being thrown into this
through the very, very
interesting student movement,
which has its
cultural components,
subcultural component,
rock and roll
component, designing
component, arty component,
catchy component, funny
component, in component,
cool component-- I
ended up in a society
where you can't date
in Serbia if you're not
a part of a student movement.
Now it really
shifts your reality
into something which is
completely different.
And one of the things the
book will tell you about--
and you'll read
it on the subway.
It's a really really,
really easy read.
And it was made for
the people who are not
experts, who are not
activists per say,
but do understand the story.
How many of you have seen
"The Lord of the Rings"?
Oh yes.
SCOTT CARPENTER:
You're at Google, man.
SRDJA POPOVIC: You
remember hobbits.
And one of the funny
things about it
is that these creatures--
little, hairy, super thrilled
about eating and smoking pot and
living in their little holes.
And they're not really
designed for change.
They're not wearing
the shiny armor.
They're not wizards.
But they are the ones who get
to the part in the history
to perform the change.
And this is the book
of little hobbits.
And whether you look at Egypt,
my friend Mohammed Adel,
you want to look at
Martin Luther King--
the guy was a village priest.
Harvey Milk-- camera shop owner.
Who are these people, wizards?
Knights?
No, hobbits.
And wherever you
look at the world,
it is the small hobbits
shaking and shaping.
So when I say, the
story of me, this
is the story of the
very, very common
and ordinary
people, some of them
who live in your neighborhood
who made a dramatic change.
And whenever you look, you'll
find a really, really cool
example.
This is not only about Serbia.
This is about the
fantastic people
who shake the Israeli state
around the idea of the cottage
cheese.
This is the story of the people
who put up the toy protest
in February, 2011 in
Siberia, making Putin
look completely ridiculous.
This is the story of very, very
many people, people like you
and me, who came out
to this understanding
that they should
change the world.
Now, the second part of the
book is the story of us.
Now, how a big part
of your history book
is related to wars-- have
you ever thought about it?
You take your history book.
How much of it is war?
How many movies have you
watched about Vietnam?
One stupid proxy completely
unimportant war in history,
but you've probably seen like
five, six, seven, 10 DVDs.
How many cool movies about
Martin Luther King, one?
How many good
movies about Gandhi?
One.
One cool about Harvey Milk.
When you look at your nonviolent
struggle DVD collection,
it's probably 3 inches.
And why so?
Because if you look in
the world we're living at,
the things which were
driving the big wars of past
in terms of the First
World War, Second World
War-- who is remembering the
Second World War ideologies?
Would we really go out
and kill each other
because we are
communists or not?
This really doesn't matter.
But when you look
in a world where
the President of the United
States is a black person,
you can see the
consequence of something
starting by Martin Luther King.
When you look in a world where
even the Republican candidate
will stand for gay
marriage, probably,
on the next American elections,
you're looking at the world
where little hobbit Harvey
Milk was successful.
So you're living in a world
shaped by nonviolent struggle.
But in a bizarre way,
you know far more
about the heroes of the past.
Look at the monuments in
New York or Washington, DC.
They're all tall
armed men on horses.
And then you find
a little Gandhi.
There is one Gandhi
monument here in New York.
And how many of
you do know where
the Gandhi is in New York?
Ah, tiny, tiny.
You need to practice.
SCOTT CARPENTER: OK, Google.
SRDJA POPOVIC: So this
is the story of us,
is that we are living in
a world where we really
need to learn more about how
important the social change is
and how we can boost it.
And now we are looking
at the story of now.
And we are looking at the world
where you turn the news on,
you see the Hong Kong, and
the Egypt, and this, and that.
It's like wherever
you look on a TV,
you have a super excited
TV anchor who says,
oh, this spontaneous
demonstration just occurs.
There are two types of protest
movements of this world.
They're either
spontaneous or successful.
So if you want to
make them successful,
you need to look at the vision
and strategy and tactics
and build unity and build
from small victories.
And I think the
reason why we made
this book is that this
knowledge is out there.
And we really wanted to
put it in a cool form
for the common
people to understand
that what shapes this world
is A, coming from hobbits.
B, this is something you
can and should do at home.
Not all of you have
Milosevic at home.
But you may have
a bully neighbor.
You may have a very
bad school district.
You may have a dog's
poop on the street
depending on the part
of town you're living.
You may have a very, very
corrupt public official
who is the reason why your
public transportation sucks,
or whatsoever.
And this is not limited to
democracies or autocracies.
This is like everywhere.
And if we understand that there
is a set of tools we can apply,
and if we join our
forces-- we are
working on making this available
as short animated videos.
We would like to work more
with the Googles of this world
to make this available
to more people,
with Wikimedia of this world.
We are teaching this
thing in Harvard and NYU.
We will have an
online course, which
is going to become available
for the people across the world,
how to build this movement.
Because what I think is
that next century will be
the century of knowledge race.
It's not the arms race anymore.
It doesn't really
matter who has tanks.
Nobody will dare to use tanks.
Or if they use tanks,
they will end up
like US and Iraq, or Putin
in [INAUDIBLE], like stocked.
It's not going to perform
the real social change.
And I think at the
end of the day--
and the last chapter of the
book is called It Has to be You.
So we need to understand that
this is our little role to take
a little injustice, fight it.
And yes, however we
are looking as hobbits,
and we're lazy and
hairy and laid back,
it is our part to change our
little parts of the world.
And to end up quoting
Tolkien once again,
the grand lesson of
this book is that, yes,
even the smallest
creature can change
the destiny of the world.
And throughout the
history, it has been
like that many, many times.
SCOTT CARPENTER:
Thank you, Srdja.
That's really powerful.
Where I wanted to dig in is
to actually go back in time
first to October, 2000 when
the campaign kind of came
to its victorious end.
And it really did happen
with very little violence.
Why do you think it didn't
involve much violence?
SRDJA POPOVIC: Because people
were trained to be nonviolent.
And I think one of the
things we need to understand
is that A, violence looks sexy.
And the person with the
gun is the favorite person
of your DVD collection.
OK, it's always "Die
Hard" and "Die Hard
with a Vengeance"
and "Die Hard 7,"
if it's not "The Terminator."
But this is, the
guy with the gun
comes in and solves the problem.
You look at the
nonviolent struggle,
and you actually understand
that it's more effective.
And a scientific study shows
that in the last century,
there were 323
different campaigns.
And nonviolent campaigns
were twice more effective.
And this is not just
the better moral choice.
It's about, you look at this
and say, if I want to succeed,
I will use the most
effective weapon.
And when you look at
the Serbian campaign,
or you look at any campaign
throughout the world,
nonviolent discipline is
one of the three principles
of success, together
with unity and planning.
How do you get there?
It is the great question.
And it is skill.
You can teach people this skill.
A, you can preach it, whether
as a religion or ideology
or a cool/noncool factor.
Because in Serbia and wars
with all of this past,
these violent guys
were not super sexy.
It was actually
the nonviolent guys
who were looking
more like the cool.
And then the second one,
you train your troops
to be nonviolent You sit
when you see the police.
You make the live chain between
you and the police force,
so you make sure that there
won't be one drunk idiot who
throws rocks.
And by the way, you look
at it from the position
of tomorrow's
newspaper, and you can
have 10,000 people in the
peaceful march singing,
and you have three drunk
idiots start throwing Molotovs.
And guess who's on the cover
page of "The New York Times"?
These three guys always.
You can count that the media
would be super violent thirsty,
and that they will send
only the message you
don't want them to send.
So last but not of
least importance,
you don't want to align
with the groups who
are potentially violent.
And this is also
one of the tricks.
And if you performed the
large scale demonstrations,
there will be black
blocks of this world
ready to come in and start
throwing stones and breaking
windows.
They love this.
They live for this.
Soccer fans in Serbia, they just
are looking at the opportunity
to attack the police.
And it's like that everywhere.
But it's your duty to
cooperate with the police
force in this case.
So it took us 10
years to evolve.
When we see the police
force ready to beat us,
like in '91, '92, we would howl.
Normally we would
do, av, av, av, av,
which is telling the police
people that they are no better
than the dogs.
But then we evolved
into the position
where we're giving them
the flowers and the cakes,
and the beautiful girls
would be in the front ranks.
And this is the beauty
of nonviolent struggle,
is to understand that if
you want to change things,
you need to pull, not push.
And this pull versus push
thing is the great evolution
which brings you to the
successful nonviolent struggle.
SCOTT CARPENTER: Well, I want
to get into technology in a bit,
but a couple more
questions about this.
I think that as we see the pain
and dislocation and violence
in Syria, where the
movement started
as a peaceful
nonviolent movement
and continued, even after some
fighting began to break out,
what do you think of
that whole situation?
Was it possible to
maintain nonviolent tactics
in the face of that
kind of violence?
SRDJA POPOVIC: There
is a whole chapter
where we are discussing
this with a Syrian group
in the book.
And actually, that
was the moment
when they were getting
people from what became
later the Free Syrian Army.
And they were super
inspired with this idea.
Oh, we need to make the hub
for the people in uniform
so they protect us if
somebody shoots on us.
Of course, it was
possible to fight Assad
by nonviolent means.
And when you look
at the first seven
months of Syrian
uprising, you can
look at the great numbers,
relatively nonviolent
demonstrations,
a lot of victims.
But number of victims on
the side of the protesters
actually grew when
they took arms.
And this is the rule.
So when you're
looking at this, you
can look at this from the
point of strategy first
and say, OK, I'm looking at
this guy, and his name is Assad,
and he sits on 100,000
strong military.
And can I imagine the
alternative to this guy,
and he's going to be Mike Tyson.
How many of you are familiar
with the name Mike Tyson?
OK, my question is, if you need
to win over the Mike Tyson,
is the boxing ring the place
that you're going to pick?
No.
He's going to eat your ears.
He's going to eat your
head in 15 minutes.
And of course you would
like to challenge him
on a game of Scrabble,
a game of chess,
and this is where you
have a certain advantage.
So avoiding the strong
points of your opponent
and looking at his weak
points is a military doctrine
of Sun Tzu, which is
like 3,000 years old.
So when you're
looking at the Assad,
the last place of the world
you want to challenge him
is the field of military.
The guy has a superior military.
You look at his wallet.
He's broke.
You want to really
challenge Assad,
you will look at the
tactics of "noncooperation."
You look at a successful
example in the past
where you have a nonviolent
struggle against the apartheid
regime in South Africa.
And then the genial
people came in
and said, let's make
the sphere of the nation
and start throwing bombs.
And then of course
Mandela got to jail,
and they got stuck
for like 15 years.
And then the last
stage of the struggle,
they say, OK, this
is the situation.
We have an internationally
isolated regime,
which needs to fund a very,
very expensive oppression.
How the hell are they
filling the budget?
And they're looking
at the budget,
and they understand
that it is actually
the majority of the black people
of South Africa are buying
goods from few South
African companies who
are paying taxes, which is
effectively funding military.
So by buying this and
by buying that, they're
funding the oppression.
They say, OK, we won't buy.
That's how we are going
to solve this problem.
And [INAUDIBLE]
regime in South Africa
was economically collapsed.
It was not militarily collapsed.
It was still one of
the healthiest military
on the African continent.
But it was
economically collapsed.
So the case in this
type of situation
is that you're looking
at the vulnerabilities
of your opponent.
The real problem with Syrians
was also very, very different.
And I think that's one of the
grand lessons of Arab Spring.
I think the real
problem was they really
were inspired to go in arms
to what happened in Libya.
So now we have a
nonviolent uprising
in Libya, which turned into
the military uprising, which
ended up with foreign
military intervention
with Gaddafi killed and
raped on the street.
And then the Syrians
took it from there
and said, OK, we would like
to see Assad raped and killed
on the street.
But guess what?
Look at Libya now.
Would you like this
scenario to have at home?
No.
Only 4% of military uprising
end up in stable democracy.
This is not because I'm
preaching nonviolence
and I'm having a little tattoo
of Gandhi on my left hand.
This is because a lot
of people participate
in nonviolent
struggle, as opposed
to the small group of
people participating
in a violent struggle.
And it's also the
kids phenomenon.
If you teach kids that the only
way to change the government
is to kill the
president, what do you
think the kid will do next time?
They'll try to
kill the president.
If you teach people that widely
popular nonviolent movement
which mobilizes the people
throughout the election
is the way to change government,
like we did in Serbia,
how do you think we're
changing governments now?
On elections.
Why do you think they're
not stealing the elections?
Because they know that
there is a price tag.
So this is a learning curve.
SCOTT CARPENTER: Let me ask
you another question that's
in the news these days.
And that is the evolution of
Putin's strategy in Ukraine.
And I know a lot of Central
Europeans and Baltic states
are really nervous about
the approach they're taking.
Because it's so subtle and so
not so subtle at the same time.
How to respond in
nonviolent ways there?
And kind of related
is, I know that you're
friends with a lot of
folks in Pussy Riot
and some of the other
Russian activists.
But that space has
shrunk so, so much.
And these two
things are related.
Putin and other regimes
have really learned
a lot over the last
10 years or so.
And they're applying
their own tactics.
So how do we respond?
SRDJA POPOVIC: Well, it's
a multilayer question.
First, I think the Ukrainian
crisis matters, and not
only because it was in
media, but because it's
a very important breaking point
of power balance in Central
and Eastern Europe.
And it also made
Putin very nervous.
Because I think the reason
why he's doing what he's doing
is that he's looking
at the Maidan, which
is the central square
in Kiev, Ukraine,
and he's imagining a
similar situation in Moscow.
And I think that grows
him growingly nervous.
When you look at
these struggles,
you could also see
a learning curve.
And one of the books that
tells a great story about this
is written by my very, very
good friend Will Dobson.
It's called The Dictator's
Learning Curve."
And he explains
how dictators find
a way to prevent these
nonviolent revolutions
before they occur.
So they will squeeze
the media space.
They will sensor the internet.
They will make the ban on some
people gathering together.
And it's kind of
the learning race.
And wherever you speak
with the clever guys--
and we are proud to have people
from Human Rights Foundation
here in the audience who
are making this great,
big Oslo Freedom
Forum once a year.
And you sit with
these top dissidents,
and you keep hearing stories.
And part of the story is
how the people overcome
these types of obstacles.
And I think one of
the ways to deal
with it is looking at
the non-political space.
And I think when you look at
the very closed societies,
Korean society, what is
becoming really closed society
in Russia, it is actually
the non-political space.
And state does not
deliver topics.
Because you look at
these countries-- and you
could look, for
example, at Russia.
There are like two great
examples in the book.
One, people were protesting
against the election
fraud in Moscow and
in St. Petersburg.
And because the
cameras were there,
people were allowed to protest.
But of course, they
couldn't follow the protest
in a little place
like Barnaul, Siberia.
So people came to this.
This is a 3,000 people place.
This is like Grinnell in Iowa,
like some really, really small
village.
And there is a square,
which is like this size.
And then the people will
build the little LEGO city
from the toys of their kids.
And they will come out
with the little LEGO toys.
And they will organize
a toy protest.
So the toys would run around
with transparents and stuff
like that.
And of course everybody
would be there.
People will tape it.
They will post it on YouTube.
And a friend of mine made
a documentary about this.
And you can see
that day one, there
were even police taping it.
So it's like everybody
was having fun.
And then of course
it went viral.
And then somebody
was really uproared
about this in the Kremlin.
And they say, no, no,
we need to prevent this.
So next day when the
Russian activists
file the request for
the demonstrations,
they got a written
response from the police
that the demonstration of 100
LEGO soldiers, 25 toy cars,
are banned.
Because the toys are
not citizens of Russia.
And only citizens of
Russia can protest.
And that was the official
paper from the police.
So now you look how the
creativity and a little bit
of bravery and the
really cool idea
can challenge the man who
spends so much money in posing
shirtless, wrestling tigers,
saving dolphins from drowning,
and [INAUDIBLE] for us.
And he's afraid of toys.
And it's like, you can look
at how the creativity always
finds a way.
So there's another Russian town.
It's really cool.
And there was a bunch of artists
who were looking at the city.
And because of
course the city is
full of the bumps, these
big holes in which you
hit your car whenever
you drive, they kind of
painted the faces of the
city officials around this.
So there'll be a mayor with a
big hole instead of his mouth,
or the governor with a big
hole instead of his mouth.
And of course what
happens in reality
is that you drive the
car, you hit the bump,
and of course you
curse-- what else?
And whom do you curse?
And the really
interesting response
from the Russian
officials was that they
tried to repaint the faces
rather than fill the holes.
So this phenomenon--
the book, of course,
there's a chapter called
Laugh Your Way to Freedom.
The idea is that there's so
many examples where people
are super creative operating
on a high-risk environment,
and using existing
political space,
and especially using
humor and creativity.
Because humor is a very powerful
weapon against the politicians
generally, not necessarily
authoritarians.
I have a sense that
the people in power
spend too much time watching
their faces in the newspaper
and on the TV and on
billboards and start
thinking about themself
as about this image
rather than about
their real selves.
And they become very vulnerable
to this type of activism,
which we of course
baptized the laughtivism.
Because this is what you do.
So there are creative ways.
There are small
acts of resistance.
There are activities which
are called dispersive tactics.
The Putins of this world will
be very effective in preventing
you going to the square.
So you don't go to square.
You go somewhere where
they don't expect you.
So there are ways you can do it.
There are like 200 different
things people can do.
And people were
doing it in the past.
Several minutes ago,
I spoke with Dan
for this little podcast.
And one of the things we said
was where technology can help.
And one of the great things
that technology does,
it helps the group
learn horizontally.
So now you don't need a mentor.
You don't need a trainer.
You don't need a
Harvard online course.
You look at how Venezuelans
can make a small viral video.
You make the one in Ukraine.
Now, the Taiwanese
take it from there.
They see it on the YouTube.
They record one themselves.
So enabling people to learn
horizontally from each other
is I think the biggest
achievement technology can
bring to this world.
And it's a great task of
organizations like Google Ideas
to make this space as open
as possible, and as available
for the people as possible.
SCOTT CARPENTER: Fantastic.
Well, we have about
15 minutes left.
So if there are questions
that you all want to ask,
we have microphones on
the left and right hand
side of the stage.
And I'd ask that you ask
the question from there,
because this whole
thing is being recorded,
so that we can
hear the question.
SRDJA POPOVIC: So
you all go to jail.
SCOTT CARPENTER: Yeah, we
know who's saying what.
SRDJA POPOVIC: Big
Brother is watching.
SCOTT CARPENTER: So if you'd
make your way to the mics--
if not, I will continue
the conversation.
I think a couple
people are coming up.
Srdja, back in the
day, the technology--
SRDJA POPOVIC: That sounds like
we are about 250 years old.
SCOTT CARPENTER: Yeah,
it does, doesn't it?
But in 2000, the internet in
Serbia wasn't terribly strong.
SRDJA POPOVIC: Inter-what?
SCOTT CARPENTER: Yeah, right.
So radio-- what was the
big technology of the day,
just very quickly?
And then we have questions.
SRDJA POPOVIC: Texting.
We would go in the kiosk and buy
this little prepaid phone card.
And then you'll
go on the computer
and send 10,000 messages.
This is the day of the election.
Milosevic is finishing.
Go out to vote, and
send this to everybody.
And we thought this was
the technology breakthrough
of the 21st century.
But it is always the
technology you have
available that you need to use.
And however technology can
be seductive and beautiful,
you need to understand that
making a website in English
wouldn't really mobilize the
grannies in rural Zimbabwe.
So it's really understanding
that technology
is a messenger for you
rather than the essence.
And there were cases in the
past where young South African
kids were trained to run
from village to village
and sing revolution.
Because this is how
they use their history.
They have an oral history.
This is not something
written in the books
or in Vietnamese DVDs.
This is the oral history.
So you use the technology
you have at your disposal.
Some of this can be
very cool and sexy.
But don't get too
obsessed with technology.
Technology itself won't
solve the problems.
Only technology
put in a good use
is going to help and solve
the problem, I think.
SCOTT CARPENTER: Please.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you.
The talk is very interesting.
I have a question around the
Occupy Wall Street movement.
And I think that was
an interesting example
of nonviolent activism.
But I didn't think it was
anywhere near as successful
as some people
hoped it would be.
And I'm wondering what
lessons we could learn
from that movement, and how they
could then be applied perhaps
in the future.
SRDJA POPOVIC: That's a topic
we discussed over and over,
and the favorite topic of my
co-writer of this book, who
hides somewhere
in the third rank.
Matt, where are you?
Say hi to everybody.
And we discussed
this over and over.
And we said, OK,
that was a thrilling
demonstration of necessity
for social change in America.
It was hitting the right
topic of inequality.
It was very nice in
mobilizing the people.
But the part of this book
is very critical about it.
Because the moment I
sat with these people--
and I had the
opportunity to meet them
at the peak of their numbers.
Because I was here
teaching at NYU.
And they appear on
Todd Gitlin's class.
And he's a professor
here at Columbia.
And he says, I want you
to meet some cool people.
They can make change.
And it took me three
hours speaking with them
to extract the answer
to the question,
if you are the king for the day,
if you are the Harry Potter,
and you can touch
America, how will it
be different from today?
And then they start telling
me about the evil banks
and evil this and evil that.
And I say, no, no,
that's not the question.
The question is, if you
are the king for the day.
And every successful
nonviolent struggle
starts with-- the second
chapter in the book
is called Think
Big, Start Small.
What is the big picture?
Where are you going?
What is your vision of tomorrow?
What do you want to achieve?
And then how are you
going to achieve this?
If you can't give me the answer
to this question in 30 seconds,
why in the world
would I follow you?
So I think they were
tremendously enthusiastic.
I think the space for
this moment is here.
You will see more
pro-equality movements
in this country in
the next 10 years.
I can put $100 on this bet.
I don't know how
they will be named.
But one of the problems is they
need to know what they want.
Second and very important
part of the story
is branding the movement.
If only these guys branded
themself 99%, then I can join.
Because I have a wife.
I have small kids.
I'm too busy doing other stuff
to just sit in Zuccotti Park.
And I think limiting yourself to
a tactic is one of the mistakes
that movements make,
which of course you
are going to understand,
because you'll read
this book on your way home.
So you will understand exactly
what I'm talking about.
And next time you have
an inequality problem,
you will be far better
equipped than the boys
and girls of Occupy.
SCOTT CARPENTER: One of
the interesting things
that we probably don't
have time to get into,
and I want to get to the
next question, but Otpor!
as a movement, once
it became successful,
the leadership went
through a big debate about,
do we become a political party?
And it was a fascinating
conversation.
Because their mission
had been achieved.
So I'm going to leave
that aside for a second,
but your question, please.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for this talk.
It's really inspiring.
Hearing the actual facts
about why nonviolence
is more effective than
violence is really, really
useful and fascinating.
I had a question.
It's the opposite of
the last question,
I think, which was, for
somewhere like North Korea,
where dissent is so
quashed, where there
are no real means that
people can congregate and get
together, how would you create
some sort of social change
somewhere like that?
SRDJA POPOVIC: Of
course there's always
this theory that this
will never work here,
because the regime
is too oppressive.
I had a great conversation
with some exiled North Koreans
recently.
And these are clever forks.
And they understand the things.
And you can look at
the mobilization slash
provocation tactics
which are recently
executed by some North
Korean exile guys.
You can look at the brave friend
of mine, Thor Halvorssen, who
is crazy enough to
use balloons and send
some content across the border,
which I appreciate very much.
And you can look at
the long term problem.
And I think the long term
problem-- how many of you
are familiar with the book
or movie called "1984"?
OK, this is George Orwell.
This is my little bible.
And one of the things
this movie tells you,
that the totalitarian
regime tend
to cut horizontal relationships
between the people,
within the families,
within the community.
So only look up to
the great leader,
or whoever represents
the great leader.
I think the trick
in North Korea,
and places like
North Korea, would be
to start building small things.
If you can organize a movement
in the neighborhood which
deals with the
question of garbage,
or whatever is mismanaged--
and there's probably
like 157 things
which are mismanaged
in the state of North Korea.
And you can become
successful on building
on non-political issues.
One of the things,
tomorrow, or day
after tomorrow,
the "Politico" will
run an excerpt of this book.
And they were fascinated with
the story about Harvey Milk.
And that was not a story
about the brave gay man
who stood up for gay rights.
That's a story about the brave
gay man who was stupid enough
to lose the election
three times putting
the topic of his sexuality.
And then he understood that
the thing he should build about
is a dog's poop.
And it is him
effectively persuading
people of San Francisco that
whether gay or straight,
he's the person who is going to
solve the problem of the dog's
poop.
And this is how he got elected.
And this is exactly
the grand lesson
of the situation in
places like North Korea.
You pick the topic.
You become successful
around solving this topic.
It's not a political topic.
Because if you try building
on a political topic,
you will end up in a
concentration camp.
So this is a stupid way to go.
The cool way to go is to look
at the small things you can do,
build this horizontal
relationship.
Once you are
becoming successful,
you're building kind of
the level of the success.
More people will join.
Plus you're filling the space
which is completely empty.
The trademark of corrupted
authoritarian regime
is bad management.
Traffic doesn't function.
Streets are full of the holes.
Nobody gets paid.
I mean, you name
it, you have it.
And you're looking
at these places
because you can't
protest politically.
Plus because it matters to
the people so much more.
When you talk to the people
from places like North Korea,
they're far more
concerned about what
they're going to eat than about
the human rights or whatsoever.
And I think one of
the tricks that you
will learn through
reading this book is
that the first
step in organizing
any nonviolent movement is
go and listen to the people.
And this is how you
distinguish why the people will
join the struggle.
And this is when you understand
that your mobilization
force lies in a dog's
poops of this world
rather than the big idea of
the free media and democracy
and stuff like that,
which we in the West--
and I include
Serbia in the West--
tend to selfishly thing
that we know what they need.
But we want to go
and listen to what
they need rather than that,
and help them build around
what they need.
At the end of the
day, if they develop
these horizontal relationships,
they will gain power.
And once they understand
that they are powerful,
then the regime will
be in deep trouble.
SCOTT CARPENTER: From
your lips to God's ears.
All right, so why don't
we take these last two
questions together,
so you, and then you,
and then you can answer them
both, or not answer them
at all, whatever you choose.
SRDJA POPOVIC: Hi.
I also found this talk
really fascinating.
And I'm looking forward to
getting sucked into your book
on the subway in the mornings.
So my question is
about in 2013, there
was a big email leak,
the Stratfor emails,
which strongly
suggested that you
had a very close relationship
with a company that
has reputation for being a
very dodgy corporate security
agency.
I'm wondering if you could
elaborate on your relationship
with Stratfor and how
you think that relates
to grassroots social democracy.
Thanks.
SCOTT CARPENTER:
All right, and--
SRDJA POPOVIC: And I'm going to
try to put two questions there.
I'm going to be cheeky.
First one, you mentioned
technology and horizontal
sharing and so forth.
Given that governments and
dictators and intelligence
agencies are basically
not only catching up,
but are the leaders
now in the technology,
do you think that's going
to hurt future revolutions?
And the second one may
be a bit closer to home.
It seems that in the
former Yugoslavia,
there's more popularity
now for the parties
than were in power in the '90s.
What's your view on
that and how that's
going to impact the next
five to 10 years there?
SRDJA POPOVIC: OK, so let's
start with the domestic issues.
It's a normal process that
within the two or three
electoral cycles, the
old guys get elected.
What I'm really thrilled
about is that in my country,
these people became
electable only
when they embraced
the very values we
were fighting for in 2000.
So you look at
Otpor! as a movement,
and you say, this movement was
about peace with neighbors,
being a part of
the European Union,
and, of course, the very idea
of democratic freedom of press,
freedom of assembly,
freedom for elections.
It was when the parties
who are now in power
embraced these values that
they became electable.
And I think one of the
things which distinguishes
successful revolutions
from successful turnovers
not followed with
successful transitions
is on what you focus.
And if you're focusing like
in Egypt on replacing Mubarak,
then you maybe end up
with Sisi, who is either
same or worse as Mubarak.
Whereas if we were building a
struggle on the values in terms
of, this is what we stand
for, it is very likely
that these values will
prevail on the society whoever
sits on the top of the pyramid.
On the topic of
Stratfor and leaks,
I've done one presentation
with these guys, which
looks very much like
this, though the venue was
a little bit less fancy.
And I have a friend
working there.
And I think the big idea of
evil secret services being
around anything is exactly
the public narrative
we want to kill with this book.
And I think the very obsession
with conspiracy theories
and the fact that
everybody believes
that there is this super
successful secret service who
are pulling the
strings everywhere
and understand the
stuff, they often
can't find their own nose.
So in my experience, I would
speak with about everybody.
I will give a
presentation to CIA.
presentation to KGB.
I would give the
presentation to FSB.
And I'll give the
presentation to Google.
If there is one single
person in the audience
I can persuade in an
organization like Stratfor
or CIA that it is the people
who make the change, not
the military, that it is the
people you should invest into,
not elites, and the only way
to do the durable change is
actually to work with
the people on the ground
and appreciate the
people on the ground
and empower the people on the
ground, I would rather do that.
So that's my point of view.
I will speak to the
very devil in order
to persuade the devil that
things should be changed.
And last but not of
least importance--
to this question of technology.
And I spent 20 minutes
speaking with Dan
about this in the podcast.
I will try to be fast.
Modern technology is super
effective in some kind
of stuff.
And there's this super
cool guy call Clay Shirky.
And you should watch his talk
called "Here Comes Everybody."
He's very, very enthusiastic
about how the technology can
bring about the mobilization.
And we had a great
discussion about it.
And I think technology does
three things very well.
It makes thing faster,
cheaper, more safe.
B, it puts a huge
price tag on violence
over the demonstrators.
Because even in a low-tech
society like Bahrain,
you see the demonstration.
There's like 50 people taping.
So it would be very difficult
to hide any kind of attempt
to do something nasty.
And last but not of least
importance in my case,
it enables you to learn.
So where this is the horizontal
learning, online learning,
this enables activists to
connect on the learning point.
Also, technology comes
with a big price.
First, we get too obsessed.
In the technological world,
as my co-writer Matt Miller
would say, everything is
about the shares and clicks.
So if you have a really
cool viral video where
you're mocking your dictator,
and you get 5 million clicks,
then you really think
that you're really
on the top of the pyramid.
And that brings you to
the Kony 2012 campaign,
which was probably the most
successful public awareness
raising online campaign ever.
But Kony, where is Kony?
He's in Uganda with
his soldiers army.
OK, so when you're
looking at the effects,
effects should be made
in the real world,
rather than being too
obsessed with the effects
in the virtual world.
We call this
phenomenon clicktivism.
And it often says, you know,
I clicked on this page.
I save one polar bear every
day like over my coffee.
But the one which
I really, really
consider dangerous, and
dangerous misunderstanding,
I think, is the phenomenon
we call occupyism.
It has nothing to do with the
social values of Occupy Wall
Street.
It has to do with the
very, very stupid intention
of the movements to copy/paste
the most dangerous, most
demanding, and very,
very risky tactics
of occupying symbolic
public space.
We could see this in Hong Kong.
We want to protest,
we must occupy.
Why the hell we must occupy?
There's so many other
things we can do.
We can whistle.
We can hit pots and pans.
We can wear symbols.
We can organize parties.
We can vote.
We can do petitions.
There's around 200
different things
we can do instead of putting
all of our parts into one place
and waiting for police to come.
Plus, if we repeat this every
day, we become predictable.
Plus, if we repeat
this every day,
where will the people go
to the toilet on day seven?
How is this square going
to look on day nine?
How the people will get
thrilled once the rain starts.
What about the rugby game?
People don't think about it.
They get too thrilled.
But I think it's a seduction
of the new media, which
enables you to gather
your number too fast.
It's like one thing if you
can assemble numbers quickly.
But if you assemble these
numbers before you're ready,
it's also a very,
very big threat,
not only because there will
be five drunk idiots who
will start throwing
Molotovs and destroy
your beautiful demonstration,
but because occupation
is such a risky and
demanding tactic.
And you want this tactic not
before you're ready, only
at the end game.
Then you do the
concentration tactics.
SCOTT CARPENTER:
Well, please join me
in thanking Srdja
for his talk today.
We really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
I also would like
Srdja's co-author
to stand up, and also for
the folks from Oslo Freedom
Forum who are here.
If you're here, please stand up.
We'd love to congratulate you.
SRDJA POPOVIC:
[BLOWS KISS] We love you.
SCOTT CARPENTER:
Yeah, fantastic.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, again,
Srdja is somebody
who we've known for
a long time and has
been really helpful in
helping us think through some
of the challenges
that we face, and what
we can do with our technology
and our skills, abilities,
to help in this cat and mouse
game that people like Srdja
face.
So again, we're up
on the 15th floor.
Come find us some time.
All right, thanks
again, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
SRDJA POPOVIC: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
SCOTT CARPENTER: Thank you, man.
It was fun.